[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de page
consacrée à la culture et la culture que
vous le savez est peut-être une des
grandes victimes de la crise sanitaire
l'alternance de fermeture de réouverture
partielle de refermeture des lieux
culturels et donne évidemment une
situation difficile parfois désespérante
pour des acteurs de la culture
d'ailleurs la culture pourra-t-elle se
relever d'une telle crise
de quelle nature est cette crise c'est
une crise financière naturellement mais
c'est peut-être aussi une crise
culturelle de ce que des français
reprendront le chemin des théâtres des
musées des cinémas après la crise et une
session des questions que nous allons
poser à nos invités stéphanie tesson
bonjour vous êtes la directrice du
théâtre de poche montparnasse vous êtes
aussi auteur metteur en scène nous
travailler beaucoup notamment pour le
mois molière de de versailles
joséphine que le match berger bonjour
bonjour vous êtes maire de plaisir vous
êtes vice président du conseil
départemental chargé de la culture
manon la maison bonjour bonjour vous
êtes artiste lyrique tout jeune artiste
d'eric on aurait dû vous voir en janvier
prochain sur la scène de l'opéra de
versailles dans les noces de figaro
malheureusement le spectacle n'aura pas
lieu
et puis lionel masse et à bonjour vous
êtes directeur de du théâtre de saint
quentin de la scène nationale d'étape de
saint quentin et dans quelques instants
nous serons rejoints par aurore bergé
qui est député de la 10e circonscription
des yvelines membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
de l'assemblée nationale et qui est très
intéressé évidemment partout le domaine
culturel
je vais commencer par vous stéphanie
tesson évidemment vous espériez la
réouverture du théâtre pour le début
décembre
comment comment vous avez vécu cette
cette situation cette refermeture en
moins jusqu'en janvier
ben comme un deuxième massue histoire du
feu il y avait déjà sorti
arrêt 1c les striction que nous avions
ici est la lettre est déjà une petite
mise en scène à la taille a4
désinfection de tout le siège entre les
spectacles les identifications d'aller
m'acheter un sol mais elle a pris à
l'extérieur comme on avait vraiment joué
le jeu avec le move it shows et pilote
l'aï vu il jours comme ça on s'adapte
pour réguler pam à sion et puis on
s'arrête puis on nous appartient c'est
un beau cadeau à nouveau les ja raison
c'est vrai que c'est pour circuits à
répétition le moral d'un beau lac soit
n'entame pas le dire mais sidération cet
art on s'était vus nous en octobre vous
étiez assez optimiste sur la sur la
tenue de la saison au théâtre de saint
quentin notamment mais dans les terres
d'une façon générale et puis pour les
trous pour tous ceux qui travaillent là
aussi vous même comment vous vivez cette
situation où on va vous dire il faut
reporter les délais les spectacles et
peut-être jusqu'à début janvier
peut-être plus tard encore
c'est jusqu'au 20 janvier effectivement
je sais pas si c'est optimiste je pense
que tu es prudent mais optimiste
nouvelle activité aussi parce qu'il faut
je pense qu'il faut avoir une capacité à
se projeter aussi ce cap
niveau plusieurs endroits d'inquiétude
si on parle uniquement du théâtre de
saint quentin
je pense que les premières décisions de
fermeture ont été compliqués à vivre
mais on les a finalement accepté lors de
l' ouverture au public ou encore dans le
travail quotidien des équipes ou des
artistes en répétition on a été
extrêmement strict dans l'application
des normes sanitaires
aujourd'hui c'est un deuxième c'est un
deuxième temps on va dire de cette
prolongation de la fermeture provoque
dans un premier temps ça a été de
l'abattement qui a très vite été
remplacé par la frustration et
l'association elle même par de la colère
depuis 10 mois maintenant on a une
équipe du théâtre qui avance dans le
brouillard comme tous les théâtres de
france derrière parce qu'une prochaine
randonnée accueillir un spectacle de la
compagnie xy c'est un spectacle à hauts
risques physiques c'est un spectacle de
cirque qui avait repris les répétitions
il ya dix jours ci à nouveau stoppée net
quant aux spectateurs parce qu'on pense
aussi beaucoup à eux ils témoignent
d'une incroyable
ma patience compréhension peut-être même
à certains moments d'une certaine contre
compassion à notre endroit
mais voilà c'est le cas du téat de
saint-quentin parmi beaucoup d'autres
après il est difficile de comprendre les
motivations de cette même de 7 2 7 6 non
réouverture
alors que il est admis et acceptée est
dit par ailleurs que des fêtes de noël
entraîneront une augmentation des cas de
contamination alors il ya aussi un
sentiment de d'infantilisation du
secteur des arts et de la culture
il ya pourtant très tôt très vite
compris accepter les règles sanitaires
strictes les amis strictement en
application et voilà on est en fait
partie des secteurs qui se sont adaptés
en un temps record à la situation
je sais qu'une comme le verger en tant
que responsable politique évidemment
aimé aussi femmes de culture vous vous
comprenez évidemment ccc réactions
parfois
d'incompréhension parfois peut-être de
colère aussi moi je les comprends
complètement je trouve qu'elles sont
parfaitement justifiées
je considère que la culture n'est
absolument pas quelque chose que l'on
doive mettre comme non indispensables ça
me semble fondamental aujourd'hui à
plusieurs titres d'abord parce que comme
le disait lionel ou ou comme le disait
stéphanie tesson il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui les artistes les
structures les théâtres tout ça souffre
énormément et on comprend pas que
justement avec toutes les mesures qui
ont été prises et qui sont prises et qui
sont d'une grande responsabilité ne soit
pas considérée comme étant je dirais
d'aider des commandes et des prises de
conscience de la part des artistes pour
faire tout ce qu'il ya à faire pour
mettre le public et les artistes en
sécurité lorsque je voudrais rajouter
aussi c'est que non seulement tous les
partenaires tous les acteurs culturels
du département mais de la france tout
entière je connais surtout le côté
départementale il est clair qu'à une
vraie souffrance une souffrance et une
incompréhension totale et puis il ya
aussi un impact sur tout ce qui est
actions culturelles auprès aussi des
élèves auprès des collèges auprès des
lycées puisque les artistes aussi
interviennent à ce niveau là et
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai décalage qui
nous pose problème
et moi je suis dans une incompréhension
totale de la part du gouvernement et
bien d'avoir encore pris cette décision
qui est une décision de report est une
décision que je ne comprends alors à
aurore bergé tête tout à l'heure qu'il
est de défendre la position du
gouvernement
manon la maison vous même en tant
qu'artiste jeunes artistes
vous sortez presque du du conservatoire
c'était l'année dernière vous aviez vos
premiers rôles qui arrivait dans l'eau
notamment dans les noces de figaro
comment vous vivez aussi cette situation
ben comme vous le disais comme le disait
qu homme politique bien bas je devais
jouer dans les moeurs a bordeaux d'abord
puis ensuite à versailles
barcelone et c'était pour moi en tant
que élèves sortant de cette consécration
vraiment j'attendais ça avec beaucoup
d'impatience et puis c'est assez rare de
se voir proposer surtout un un rôle dans
un opéra national après même pas un an
de après je produise quoi donc là
j'étais déjà en quand j'appris laval à
bonn avril se dit bon pas grave on va
continuer à travailler et d'envié va
arriver au pouvoir
un roman conscience et à ce moment là et
là des locaux finement puis la nation
donc je sais assez compliqué c'est
surtout difficile de n'avoir aucune
perspective surtout de se dire quand
même jusqu'où on va tenir comment on va
tenir
donc je continue à travailler j'essaie
de me dire que que ça va reprendre je
suis d'avoir vraiment beaucoup de nature
juste nature très positif donc
heureusement je tire une prouesse que
vient et je continue à travailler avec
des ensembles aussi et j'ai des petits
ensembles ils soient requises ensemble
ça coûte moins cher aussi qui a employé
pour des théâtrales
donc je me dis aussi que si on continue
à bien travailler
perdez beaucoup ram de concert et un peu
tout soit prêt au moment de la
couverture peut-être justement et on a
eu évidemment en préparant cette
émission beaucoup de beaucoup de
réactions beaucoup de vidéos qui nous
sont arrivées de ta bouche vous propose
de voir un petit extrait ce c'est un
garçon qui s'appelle thomas gaz qu'il
fondateur de l'association cinoche de
magny les hameaux et il dit bah comment
vingt maisons qui s'occupe du cinéma
espère espérer en tout cas la
réouverture rapide des dessins et des
lieux de deux lieux de culture et on
espère que les salles vont pouvoir
ouvrir pour que le public puisse
retrouver
c'est ce lien social 7,7 bassett ce
loisir d'aller au cinéma ou dans une
salle de spectacles de s'asseoir sur un
siège de regarder avec son petit pop
corn
je pense que ça manque et on a hâte
qu'une chose c'est de rouvrir et en
cendre après aurore bergé merci beaucoup
de nous rejoindre
rappel vous êtes députée de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines et membre
de la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation
vous êtes quelqu'un qui me dit est
d'ailleurs pour la réouverture des lieux
culturels qui est très intéressé à la
culture comment vous vivez cette
situation et comment vous comprenez vous
voyez évidemment parfois
l'incompréhension la colère des acteurs
culturels
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
leur répondre c'est évidemment une
situation qui est des pieds très
douloureuse quête douloureuse d'abord
pour les acteurs du monde culturel qui
ne peuvent plus exercer leur profession
leur métier qu'ils ont peur pour
certains d'entre eux de disparaître sans
vraiment parce que quand on est une
petite équipe artistes y ait dans une
compagnie on a bien la nécessité
l'impérieuse nécessité est bien de
pouvoir évidemment continuer à exercer
ce renard et donc notre enjeu élus anne
berger qu'on soit en collectivités
territoriales qu'on soit ici à
l'assemblée nationale c'est comment on
fait en sorte pendant cette période où
la fermeture a du reste de mise avec des
risques aussi malheureusement sur les
émois avoir les années qui viennent bien
de faire en sorte on se connaît un
soutien suffisamment fins qu'il
parvienne au bon endroit c'est à dire
que non seulement on doit continuer à
soutenir des lieux qui sont déjà à des
lieux subventionnés et on doit faire en
sorte aussi que toutes les compagnies
artistiques et les moyens de continuer à
vivre et c'est ça la difficulté en fait
majeur qu'on a dans cette crise c'est
qu'on a une musique
j'ai cité des statuts multiplicité des
situations
vous savez le monde de la culture est à
la fois extrêmement diversifiée mais
aussi éclater éclaté dans sa
représentation est la plus grande
difficulté elle est là c'est faire en
sorte que le soutien arrive au bon
endroit pour qu'on n'ait pas des
artistes qui renonce à être artiste
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus assumer les
mois qui viennent les semaines qui
viennent ou qui reste du fait de la
crise donc votre votre travail avec va
être d'essayer de faire en sorte que bon
là il puisse passer ce cap ce cap
difficile au fait c'est ça oui nous
n'apprendrons il est là on savait qu'on
a évidemment eu des moyens en urgence
qui ont été extrêmement puissant je
pense qu'on est le pays au monde qui a
le plus mobilisé pour le secteur
culturel en moyens budgétaires
financiers c'est une certitude vous avez
une année blanche pour les intermittents
ont regardé d'ailleurs pour qu'elle
puisse être probablement même étiré dans
le temps encore par rapport à celles et
ceux qui n'ont toujours pas pu
évidemment continuer à exercer leur
métier ou qui n'ont pas pu retrouver
deux dates puisque évidemment un certain
nombre d'entre elles ont été annulées ou
reportées avec un risque haussier
d'embouteillage d'ailleurs pour l'année
2010 en termes de programmation que ce
soit sur le spectacle du banc ou sur le
haut sur le cinéma c'est de faire en
sorte que ces moyens d'urgence continue
avec cette protection de l'emploi
culturel puisse évidemment continuer ça
c'est le premier enjeu c'est continuer à
soutenir la diversité des lieux
culturels continuent à soutenir
l'itinérance soit si essentiel sur sur
les territoires et puis assumer aussi de
se dire que l'impact il est pas
uniquement sur 2020 2021 mais que
l'impact en terme de programmation
l'impact en termes de diversité
culturelle ils vont se mesurer sur 2022
et sur 2023 et donc il faut que le
soutien de l'état
le soutien des collectivités locales il
doit pas uniquement pour cette année
d'urgence et de crise absolue mais qu'il
perdure sur un moyen long terme et qu'il
ne s'étiole pas dans les deux trois
années à venir
justement stéphanie tesson et lionel
masse et à vous programmez vos
dès l'été afin de vous êtes vous être
les responsables ça pose évidemment des
problèmes énormes c'est le fait de
concret ou vous qu'on referme qu'on
réouvre à nouveau qu'on referme
peut-être plus tard comment comment s'en
sortent dans la programmation même d'un
théâtre stéphanie tesson géant les
artistes continuent à travailler
sereinement et on essaie en espèces ou
un moment donné en espérant être les
favoris de ce qu'on sait même si qu'en
janvier éventuellement donc sais même
pas si c'est la négation change tout
aussi notre économie donc les artistes
travail rapidement
on est dans le pur pour dollar en ce
moment les artistes travaillent sont
pleinement les addictions mais ça crée
forcément un emprunt à péage est
forcément samara et chier à chacun et à
mation mais une changer un add-on
nouvelles inscriptions que le théâtre
vient à devenir un événement alors si à
l'aube faire entrer dans les moeurs
comme les habitudes quotidiennes advenir
événementiel size au fur et à la faveur
festival fait et alors ça lui donne
certainement de plus vieux de
spectateurs et aux yeux des artistes
peut-être ça va lui faire les choses
autrement et lors les obliger à aller à
des choix ou actionnement j'ai eu
exigeant et je ne le fais pas vous
prévoyez évidemment la programmation
elles se sentent prêts mis très en
avance et vite et donc ça bouleverse
totalement votre votre calendrier
mais bon la une
j'étais infinie d'adaptation on le
savait là on est bien mais elle est
immense mais je pense que le deuxième
niveau d'inquiétude et c'est ce qui est
évoqué mais aussi par empêcher ce sont
les artistes primable en spectacle ce
sont des mois de montage de production
ce sont des mois de répétitions et quand
le sont entre le spectacle n'a pas été
vu jouer en public il n'existe pas la
confrontation au public fait partie
intégrante d'une oeuvre ce que j'ai pu
qui disait un tableau de picasso dans un
coffre fort en suisse
ce n'est pas de l'art et c'est pour ça
que les artistes créent des spectacles
des oeuvres qu'elles soient vues et
quelques elle résonne et le drame c'est
que des mois de novembre décembre
janvier sont des périodes beaucoup de
spectacles sorte ce qu'on appelle les
créations dans le jargon peuvent être
vus par des programmateurs pour être
programmé et s'est enfui vente
aujourd'hui ces spectacles sont pour
beaucoup mort né il en est d'ailleurs de
même pour un bon nombre de films qui ne
vont pas trouver d'écran lorsqu'on va
quoi reprendre une activité normale donc
non ce qu'a dit sur le spectacle vivant
il n'y a pas que ça ce que tous les
secteurs qui sont infectés bref on est
entré dans une sorte de cycle très
complexe pour les artistes là encore
effectivement ça ira jusqu'à 2022 2023
2024 et les conséquences se feront
sentir pendant toutes ces années là
alors même si nous avons la grande
chance d'être dans un pays ça c'est
important de le rappeler qui a créé un
filet de sécurité pour les artistes
les compensations financières pour
importantes qu'elles soient ne peuvent
résumer un engagement politique
vis-à-vis de la place de la culture et
de l'art et là on arrivera un troisième
un troisième niveau d'inquiétude mais
peut-être pas aussi si on va l'aborder
toute heure c'est la culture c'est
l'inquiétude c'est de savoir quelle est
la nature au fond de cette crise est ce
que ça dépanne en crise culturelle
mais aurore bergé alors je veux pas du
tout mettre en porte à faux avec la
majorité tout ça mais est-ce que intime
où vous auriez préféré une autre
solution pourrait vous aurait préféré
une roue ya ouverture plus rapide où
vous comprenez après tout il ya des ja
il ya quand même un impératif sanitaire
très important
et on peut aussi comprendre la position
du gouvernement de parcs ouvrir trop de
lieux en même temps vous avez je crois
que tout le monde aurait aimé pouvoir
rouvrir l'ensemble des lieux culturels
et le plus tôt possible quand même qu'il
n'est pas besoin de fermer du tout donc
je crois que la question elle n'est pas
là la question elle a été un moment de
faire un arbitrage non en considérant
qu'on est moins protégé dans un lieu
culturel parce que c'est pas ça qui a
été dit mais en considérant qu'à partir
du moment où on devait éviter au maximum
les déplacements on devait équiper au
maximum le brassage ils ont préféré
faire ce soit là qui est pas un choix de
gaieté peur enfin vous imaginez bien
qu'à vous de la culture
elle saute pas de joie en disant tiens
ce matin est ce que finalement je vais
pas faire exprès de laisser les fêtes
des théâtres les cinémas où l'on faisait
par l'ensemble des deux cultures permet
donc je pense que personne ne peut
penser que ça après c'était certain en
effet tu viens d'être au 10 c'est à dire
que quatre enjeux et les évidemment pas
uniquement un enjeu de demain tient
budgétaire oui il va falloir le faire
très importante et solide et sur la
durée mais c'est avant tout la capelle
c'était évidemment des déserts tout cas
retrouver leur public et c'est ça
l'enjeu qu'on va avoir en effet que le
théâtre je devienne pas juste un jeu
événementiel reprennent dans les
habitudes et dans l'intimité de nos vies
or évidemment on en a été privé pendant
de longs loin et avec ses difficultés
avec ce virus avec tes risques fait sain
de réouverture et d'arrêt je pense qu'il
faut surtout qu'à partir du moment où on
rouvre début janvier je me souhaite très
sincèrement ce soit une réouverture
pérenne qu'on n'est pas sèche et claquer
tout à fait délétère on trouvera
quelques semaines quelques mois avec
toute une programmation qui a dû être
remise en place
recalé à les spectateurs qui est aussi
un grand rôle pour et la confiance et
qui n'attendent à mon avis que ça que
notre revenir en ligue 2 culturel pour
ensuite le pop et donc c'est ça aussi
cette frange non seulement la bonne
décision au moment de l'arrêt aurait
tu veux mais de donner de la visibilité
au monde culturel en le disant
maintenant bonne fois pour toutes vous
êtes ouvert et vous allez pouvoir le
rester
quitte encore une fois ce qui en effet
des conditions tout le monde se doute
bien qu'à contient du mans on va rouvrir
rouvrira pas dans les conditions que
nous connaissions il y a un an et tous
les vieux se sont adaptés les musées les
salles de concerts de cinéma le théâtre
filet puis tout le monde s'est adapté
s'affaire maintenant l enjeu c 1 1
visibilité en matière de soutien
budgétaire et aux lieux culturels et aux
artistes et aux retards et une
visibilité sur la capacité à rouvrir et
à pouvoir créer des enjeux de
programmation sur le long terme
c'est dans l'embouteillage m'avait ont
évoqué malheureusement va aussi vous
êtes n'aurait pu être finalement une
opportunité je pense par exemple aux
salles de cinéma
l'afflux fed comme entièrement de cette
réouverture en décembre aurait pu être
une formidable opportunité d'exposition
des films français parce que justement
on avait très peu de films
internationaux qui étaient avait pris le
risque d'être reprogrammé dans cette
séquence
à partir du moment laisse fermer à
l'embouteillage un moment fait on va
avoir en concurrence par exemple des
films français qui sont très attendus
mais aussi tous les films internationaux
pour décaler leur sort ce qui
s'apparente donc il ya aussi cette heure
ne pas mettre à mal la diversité
culturelle dans notre pays de notre pays
à ce qu'on aurait ça fait fait donc d'où
la visibilité qui naissent mois dont les
enjeux sont très importants et les
dossiers difficiles à traiter
mais justement parlons un peu de la
nature de cette crise joséphine comme
dispersée par exemple on voit un garçon
comme mathieu kassovitz qui aimait tant
cette de cinéma qui est acteur qui dit
au fond pour la réouverture des salles
c'est pas très important parce que
finalement les salles de cinéma dans
quelques temps n'ira plus on va rester
chez soi pour aller au cinéma
donc on va changer de pratiques
culturelles est-ce que vous pensez que
derrière cette crise sanitaire il ya
aussi pour la culture une prise culturel
si vous parlez de et si l'on parlait de
moyens peut-être qu'effectivement cette
crise a permis de démontrer que on peut
aussi communiquer au niveau de la
culture d'une autre façon en évoquer il
n'y a pas eu quelques jours justement le
fait de toute cette dynamique qu'il y a
eu autour des réseaux et c'est là qu'on
a pu voir la puissance culturelle et des
la puissance imaginative et artistiques
de nos de nos acteurs et de nos artistes
dans tous les domaines justement par le
biais des réseaux alors est-ce que c'est
là dessus qu'il faut compter une
ambiance évidemment le spectacle vivant
est quelque chose de fondamental et
c'est peut-être un petit moyens
supplémentaires qui a permis en tout cas
de créer le lien est de maintenir le
lien avec la population ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que oui les périodes
de crise créés très souvent des
nouveautés c'est une période un peu
d'innovation qui est un plus mais en
tout cas il ya quelque chose qui est
important à dire c'est que moi je croise
énormément de personnes dans la rue qui
très souvent ne me parlez pas forcément
de culture ne me parlez pas forcément de
spectacles qui aujourd'hui me disent
combien il ré attendent tout cela même
si ce n'était pas forcément des
personnes qui allaient mais par le biais
je dirais de ces innovations entre
guillemets si vous le permettez
l'expression de voir les artistes d'une
autre façon par un autre lien par un
autre biais a donné aussi cet élan
d'avoir envie de retourner voir les
harkis de retourner dans les salles de
retourner dans les musées de retourner
dans les salles d'exposition parce que
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
y'a pas uniquement je dirais les
artistes qui sont sur plateau qui
s'offre actuellement ce sont aussi des
artistes qui travaillent chez eux ce qui
est important aussi de dire c'est que la
population a qu à choisir les habitants
ont pu constater que les artistes se
travailler pendant cette période il faut
le dire c'est super important
moi je sais que dans des théâtres
aujourd'hui qui sont fermés peut-être
que je devrais pas le dire mais il ya
des artistes qui travaillent
intérieur de c2c de ces lieux qui
arrivent à se réunir en petits groupes
pour faire des lectures pour travailler
les perdre au travail les artistes
sculpteurs travail donc l'innovation
certes à peut-être accompagné toute
cette période
mais il ya aussi un élan très fort de la
part de la population je n'attends que
ça de voir cette réouverture pour
pouvoir voir que la population revient
encore puissants nombre auprès de nos
artistes canaux tellement tellement
tellement besoin
stéphanie tesson quand vous avez
réouvert le théâtre de poche
montparnasse à votre père philippe
tesson a parlé d'un acte de résistance
donc d'ici à des résistances et qu'il ya
peut-être des collabos mais résistance
aussi vis-à-vis de quoi résistance face
aux risques de mort dont il parlait
résistance face à oui c'est ça une
certaine acceptation totale de 2 voilà
de se renfermer chez soi et sa
résistance papa s'est réuni à d'ailleurs
où les citoyens français on a quelque
chose à coimères en font la colère et
elle n'est arrivée que très récemment
parce que d'être témoins je veux 7,2 et
ces mesures qui ont détruit ce mois le
gouvernement appelle non c'est non
disons qu'après bien à l'ombre
finalement il m'a alors que c'est le
président c'est donc raison c'est une
question et nous tenir à la tribune ont
négocié on pourra pas eu je sais pas
c'était pendant la longue mais de le
mans kaddour l'a ouverte ni gauche a
book où il ya même fait certainement
fonction de la colère
pardon je vous interromps la liaison est
assez mauvaise rocco je vous demande de
vous re re j'ai aimé réduite à signaler
c'est un peu mieux la wii je ne font que
la résistance
parallèment confie-t-on au mois de
septembre avons inscrit d'abandonner
toutes les poules emma je pense que les
cotillons et eux c'est le lieu de me
revois si on ne va pas spectateur le
lion d'or
traduction la mesure subjectif de
chagrin
1 mission aujourd'hui résistance
seraient plus haut dit croyons et quoi
qu'en dise oui je suis désolé c'était
pas dit mais la liaison et on vous on
vous comprend très peu et essayer de
dette de vous pour essayer peut-être de
vous de vous et de revenir parce que là
c'est là où on comprend pas très bien
excuser moi on évidemment il ya d'autres
derrière tout ça il ya eu le mode
essentiel qui a été qu'ils étaient
prononcées les activités essentielles
celles qu'ils ne sont pas est ce que
c'est un mot que vous
reprenez votre quota prête aux dires des
gens qui font qu'il joue au théâtre et
au cinéma qui vont dans les musées qui
des artistes qu'il ne faut pas un métier
essentiel c'est peut-être un mot assez
maladroit oui d'ailleurs porte parole du
gouvernement lui-même l'a reconnu en
disant que en effet on ne pouvait pas
avoir deux catégories à la fois ceux qui
sont des biens essentiels des acteurs
essentiels du monde économique et ceux
qui ne le serait pas c'est n'est pas un
avis à plusieurs titres pour le monde de
la culture déjà parce qu'on oublie que
le monde de la culture ce qu est une
industrie en balade culturelle
c'est dans ces pourvoyeurs en croissance
avoir notre activité que ce soit dans un
territoire ou à l'international ne
souhaite un point de vue économique et
industriel le plein du monde culturel il
est essentiel dans notre pays en terme
d'emploi et l'attractivité et puis
évidemment essence mais a commis on a
bien évidemment pendant le premier
continent le plus strict que nous avons
eues avec évidemment la coupe permis de
maintenir à quel point évidemment une
appétence qui est une extrêmement bonne
santé justement pour le monde rural
donc ça a été essentielle à notre salle
est apparente mais probablement d'autant
plus parce que l'un spéciale était
affadi affaibli parce qu'on pouvait pas
se retrouver donc à la culture quelle
qu'elle soit et où qu'elles se comprime
on a eu cette possibilité là après uni
on a eu des nouvelles parlement de lien
et que les artistes les plus mous qui
ont pu se développer mais moins de
rapports qu'on fera jamais défaut parce
que vous avez à avoir au même moment la
gauche ont fait des vagues dans des
esprits ont évolué sur les sables est ce
que je ne souhaite pas et je ne je pense
qu'on est sur qu une chance c'est que
cette fois que votre wii d'abord 2005
vivement demain
proville on a plus cinéma cartier si on
n'a plus à divers
économiquement des oeuvres et je suis
prêté des sommes est uniquement des
oeuvres comme j'ai déjà pour la
diversité culturelle le financement de
ses oeuvres dont deux ouïes de diverses
et de la création culturelle que pour en
avoir et de titrer peur pour la
diffusion ensuite qui pourraient exister
et je crois qu'on a besoin de défendre
la diversité aussi on ferme une fois des
lieux culturels et cela passe notamment
par une salle de cinéma mario la maison
voilà justement vous êtes artiste vous
êtes confrontés directement à cette
crise là comment ça se passe pour vous
vous continuez à travailler vous
continuez à faire des répétitions vous
êtes vous là évidemment vous êtes seul
canton des chanteuses doerig c'est
compliqué de répéter ou travailler seul
tout à fait oui où je travaille chez moi
dans ma petite salle de travail avec des
boules quiès d'ailleurs pas ce que
deschamps eric c'est pour les oreilles
les fois et je travaille beaucoup
beaucoup aussi sur du solo sur des airs
d'opéra pour pour des auditions parce
que les auditions continuent d'ailleurs
c'est super j'en aurai 2 ou 3 en janvier
et des fois je me demande aussi pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle continue sachant
que comme vous savez quand un opéra est
programmée il est comparé les programmes
et 2,3 en avant sur les programmations
sont très très long terme
mais c'est déjà fabuleux de pouvoir
avoir eu un but pas et ensuite j'ai la
chance d'avoir du coup autour de moi et
chef de chant et des professeurs aussi
pas très loin je viens aix en provence
et une chef de chant à marseille qui est
super en ce moment est d'ailleurs allé
voir dans deux heures donc ça ça me
permet aussi de travailler et puis
ensuite j'ai plusieurs ensembles et donc
en pâture à capella et la bru la chance
malgré le configure d'être programmé par
la vidéo en décembre et donc nous sommes
venus pour préparer le concert on
continue à travailler
on a travaillé sur tout
à répéter aussi piano chant avec
lesquels on a des auditions à des
concours peut-être en janvier aussi
voilà c'est un ça va
le moral est plutôt bon parce qu'on a du
travail sur la planche même si on n'a
pas encore de rémunération et de
concerts d'après oui lionel masse et à
en parler avec stéphanie tesson tout à
l'air de du mot qu'avait employé
philippe tesson justement de nous de
résistance qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être d'être un peu
résistance par rapport à d'autres doit
se faire général j'avais le sentiment
qu'on avait été très sage voire
peut-être un peu trop peu attentiste
alors je sais pas si c'est le terme de
résistance on va le terme de résistance
je l'attribué à beaucoup d'autres choses
non c'est vrai que je peux revenir sur
cette décision unilatérale de classe et
l'art et la culture dans la catégorie
des actifs qui donne essentielle oui ça
ça donne envie de ça nous touche
et d'ailleurs ça dépasse très largement
et c'est ça que je voulais dire si tout
à l'heure ça dépasse très largement la
question des artistes de la place des
artistes et sa touche combien de la
vision qu'on peut avoir de l'homme
est-ce qu'on ait que des
télétravailleurs des consommateurs qui
se satisfont et se satisferont de
pouvoir faire leurs courses de noël
pour moi ça traduit au delà de la
fermeture d'été td théâtre ou des
établissements culturels et artistiques
un choix politique un choix de société
qui est inquiétant pouvoir même qui est
désespérant dans la présentation que
l'on pourrait avoir eu l'idée qu'on
pouvait avoir du monde d'après moi c'est
ça qui me pour moi c'est la chose c'est
finalement la chose la plus importante
je veux pas dire que la fermeture des
théâtres est tanné et ses conséquences
anthony phénomène mais je pense que
c'est la valeur symbolique dont on parle
peu mais on va parler de beaucoup de
choses très pratique mais la valeur
symbolique de cet acte de l' immense est
immense mais c'est aussi pour vous c'est
aussi pour ça que je pense un certain
nombre d'acteurs de la culture voire la
totalité des acteurs de la culture des
arts vivants
plus exactement
ont décidé de se mobiliser et je pense
arriver et on a eu cette sensation ce
besoin de se mobiliser qui étaient
arrivés dès le vendredi matin les
annonces ont été faites jeudi soir dès
le vendredi matin on était tous en
liaison avec les autres parce que il ya
quelque chose d'inacceptable dans sept 7
ce futur que qui il semble pour nous
offre là où la dimension artistique et
culturelle et finalement extrêmement
réduite bon ben j'ai justement ce qui
est peut-être difficile à supporter pour
beaucoup d'acteurs dans cette crise
c'est au fond l'incertitude dans
laquelle on découpe comprendre aussi les
difficultés de gouverner dans face à une
situation qui est totalement incertaine
totalement imprévisible oui je crois
qu'on est tous confrontés en ce moment à
cette incertitude qui conçoit un quels
que soient les secteurs d'activités dans
lesquels on peut évoluer
qu'on soit ait eu ou qu'on soit artiste
auteur le secteur le secteur d'activité
au sein du vent culturel on s'offrait la
difficulté justement c'est que ce qu'on
nous demande en plus à nous élus ces
données nous de la visibilité donnez
nous des assurances redonner de la
sécurité par rapport à nos métiers la
manière avec laquelle on va pouvoir
demander exact or cette crise est
d'abord une crise sanitaire
avant d'être une crise économique qui
risque aussi d'avoir des conséquences
sociales et on en perçoit d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui déjà avec mon séquences
importantes en termes de pauvreté donc
la difficulté mais là c'est quoi on a un
monde culturel qu'est légitime qu'ils
nous demandent un suivant que des
certitudes de la visibilité c'est ça
qu'on doit normalement pouvoir donner et
dans cette crise sanitaire
on jongle en permanence avec des
incertitudes voyez bien sûr la question
du vaccin qui posent mille et une
questions d'acceptabilité sociale de
capacités françaises se faire vacciner
celles et ceux qui nous demandent les
airs et ouverts des lieux culturels
va des restaurants au départ sur les
mêmes français qui nous disent ne
souhaitent pas vacciner meilleurs
lendemains de pouvoir être protégés vous
voyez bien aussi en permanence il faut
savoir changer avec sa dose seule
certitude on doit aujourd'hui pouvoir
donner au monde culturel c'est d'avoir
une certitude de soutien le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte qui doit pouvoir être
portée évidemment sur le monde culturel
et encore une fois publiquement ce
projet mené en 2021 sur le long terme et
compte en l'état comme collectivités
locales savez bien à quel point on est
des co financeurs et d'ailleurs le
secteur privé qui peut largement
contribuer évidemment au soutien et qui
le fait de manière extrêmement
récurrente mais qui s'est rétracté pour
des raisons assez évidente
le mécénat va pas être extrêmement
florissant cette année aujourd'hui
beaucoup de lieux culturels en dépendent
on parlait dernier rick à voyez bien
qu'extrêmement temps et puissant pour le
monde numérique par exemple donc il faut
d'abord qu'on arrive à donner cet
engagement là et ça ne ferons pas et
c'est vrai je rejoins sont en service et
l faut pas non plus que dans la manière
avec une adresse vous la manière avec
laquelle faites et elles sont parfois on
oublie le mot culture n'en donne le
sentiment finalement en effet à côté ce
serait pas aussi essentiel des banques
au secteur alors que ça justement une
valeur symbolique je reprends maintenant
les évidemment qu 30 c'est à dire que si
on a une raie au fait un bond de 13
patients après 24 ans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent mon arme
progression la capacité déjà recouvert
en coupe du monde d'avant mais comme ce
monde d'avant il est affaibli parce
qu'on a ce qui faisait l'identité de
notre pays ce qui faisait sa singularité
ce qui faisait cette diversité avec qui
s'est affaibli à fadi par contre sur le
territoire on n'aura plus les festivals
sur les territoires on a des compagnes
artistes qui ne pourront continuer à
exister
est ce qu'on aura les artistes des
auteurs des artistes plasticiens qui
auront dû renoncer
à leur métier mais tout simplement et
alors faute de pouvoir l'exercer une
faute de roms vivant alors à quoi bon ou
un service impérativement une fois
maintenir ce soutien sera alors
justement puisque vous parlez d'une
bombe d'après peut-être aux vins aborder
cette question
roselyne bachelot la bintje de la
culture espère que pouvoir sortir par le
haut de cette crise en définissant une
nouvelle culture dit elle une culture de
conciliation entre le numérique et le
patrimoine
horrobin j'ai peut-être vous demandez
peut-être de préciser ce que ce que
peut-être la ministre de la culture veut
dire et puis les réactions d d d d
autres participants ensuite c'est
certain que pendant tout cas pendant la
partie du continent et pas uniquement
sur le monde de la culture
c'était le cas par exemple sur toute la
partie éducative on a eu une
accélération qui a été extrêmement
importante en termes de numérisation et
d'accès par le numérique aux zèbres
codes culturels
c'est formidable ça ne reste pas mais ça
ne sera jamais que nous faisons c'est à
dire qu'on a recours à développer un
certain nombre de nouveaux outils de au
procès
la compagne et la numérisation là on va
discuter et nous dans le cadre du budget
justement entre soir sur ce pour rappel
les balcons virtuel peut-être sonné de
la capacité potentiellement permettre
des complémentaires qui prend auprès d'
avoir accès via le numérique est en
direct à des représentations théâtrales
on aimerait pour la prière soutien
budgétaire qui soit et sur ce point là
on est enfin un seul espace qui
permettent aux français au site si vous
trouvez dans l'offre culturelle
existante et dans l'offre culturelle de
proximité à laquelle ne peuvent avoir
accès dieu visuel public aussi je trouve
pleinement son rôle tu la capacité à
programmer et après avec la culture et
par un certain type de culture et pas
uniquement à certaines zones qui s'est
évidemment
est excellent mais encore une fois ça ne
remplacera ça et ça ne doit pas là c'est
surtout la capacité avait à être au même
moment au même endroit dans une salle de
côté al de spectacles sur un opéra à
être confrontés à des oeuvres dans un
musée il ya plein de petits qui sont
intéressés polémique propolis est
tellement intéressant permettre aux
personnes qui se font plus éloignés même
territorialement d'accès à la culture
d'accès aux fusées votre coin d'un coup
par le numérique avoir accès mais
découvre elle la divette exceptionnel on
a rarement vu au musée mais ça remplace
pas d'accord vous avez de faire venir à
des enfants qui n'ont jamais été au
louvre c'est au château de joux dans des
petits musées une idée parce que c'est
là qu'on va se créer potentiellement une
réaction cynique la culture peut avoir
un excellent accès à un vrai changement
si sur un conifère démenti tous les
enfants de ce groupe
mais ça veut dire que par la
confrontation avec moyens mais préserve
la capacité à part florent plateau des
artistes jouer produire je joue au foot
ça c'était là rien ne pourra jamais
stéphanie tesson vous ne pouvait être
que d'accord parce que ce que vient de
dire obervé que c'est à dire que rien ne
remplacera cette émotion d'aller dans un
théâtre d'avoir des acteurs face à soi
qui joue pour vous elle sera jamais ça
c'est évident ailleurs les petits soucis
techniques
moi jamais un acteur et non ce que je
vais bien
pour aller un peu plus loin que de
parler réflexion engagée je pense tour
parce que parce que je suis a requis en
termes artistiques et je me dis que
cette situation on en a un peu des dents
la véhicule d'une équipe à lens sur 7
cette mise en arrêt de la cub
purification gens pensent à la belle au
bois dormant a vécu dans les siècles
dans des situations similaires et nous
disait il ya à chaque
il ya eu une sorte ulation une
transformation d inspiration des
exigences comme disait tout à l'heure un
artiste continue de jouer à rêver d'une
loi et même si les enfermer show
lalalala résistants complémentaire a vu
ce qu'elle produit pendant les périodes
de guerre de deux périodes de disette
pendant les périodes en deux fermement
artistes sont là mais aussi politiques
pour qu'ils ont aimés penone peut
imaginer qu'il en sortira des merveilles
en termes de création au mot si on sait
que j'essaye de voir le bon côté des
choses iphone fièvre sur brad et nous
sommes frappés parce que nous sommes des
départs du parlement et et c'est le
second on a deux pas en danger et on
continue à rêver elle nous entrepreneurs
c'est plus difficile parce qu'il met la
fab est bien la macif annonce à
l'échelle de 4 qui est une entreprise
privée soutenue
on y entre par le ministre de la culture
a le biais de l'association du privé le
biais d'un mail à youtube
il y à des aides ça c'est certain
banques sont en train de crever de faim
et est en cela un autre reconnaissant la
résistance vous allez mon père elle se
joue à fond en comble ans et plus en
termes de taille et qu'il va falloir
tenir bon et là il va pouvoir tenir bon
techniquement et mais aussi à bord à la
reconsidération notre mission
pas parce que nous voulons c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu une sorte de quels types de
pêches qui ont été intégrés à ce jour
nous sommes montés du spectacle ça nous
oblige mais certainement être attentif
devant initialement dans le choix on au
désir de proposer aux spectateurs une
manière de par la vie est la lumière de
cette crise ont émergé certainement
notre désir de programmation autres et
sierre pression à une artiste les qui va
en sortir les choses c'est intéressant
ou pas sélection va être le mot d'ordre
de cette
cette prochaine réouverture et c'est
quand on y va
mais la résistance et demi ce qu'il faut
tenir et qui nuit à et à imaginer et av
yahia a programmé dans un duel mais
c'était justement si on parle de ce qui
se passe dans le monde du théâtre
notamment
on voit bien quand même que cette crise
sanitaire commencé à influer sur les
hauteurs allez allez allez allez
peut-être les obliger à écrire un peu
autrement ou à penser à cette société un
peu autrement déjà oui les artistes sont
façon le produit leur environnement donc
le numérique et est très présent dans
les arts dans les arts vivants notamment
des arts numériques aussi
et la crise a accéléré le processus nous
on adule était attendue aussi s'adapter
je pense que on concilier les deux com
com de swat
roselyne bachelot 7 c'est déjà une
réalité qu'on peut aider mais j'insiste
aussi sur sur sur une autre chose ces
calculs usant investira dans le
numérique plus
en parallèle on aura besoin qui existe
aussi des lieux où les gens se
retrouvent c'est à dire si on ne tient
pas compte de ce besoin de se retrouver
il y aura un moment rejet massif du
numérique or en le wagon aujourd'hui le
numérique et nous on nous importe il
importe il apporte aux artistes c'est
pourquoi il est important que dans le
plan du ministère il sera aussi question
de rendre les lieux de spectacles ou les
musées accueillant pour tous et pas
seulement pour les habitués des théâtres
qu'on puisse en faire des lieux dans
lesquels on a envie de se retrouver au
delà même de la fonction spectacle et de
la fonction oeuvre moi j'ai toujours cet
exemple delà de la médiathèque tu avril
à une dizaine ou une quinzaine d'années
une vingtaine d'années les des
politiques se sont demandés comment les
bibliothèques devait encaisser ce
changement du numérique et il était
question à un moment de tout passer au
numérique autres on se rend compte
aujourd'hui lorsque l'on voit là par
exemple à la médiathèque du havre que le
numérique est présent mais que ce qui a
été travaillé c'est véritablement les
espaces d'accueil les espaces où les
gens les lecteurs ont envie de se
retrouver
je pense c'est un point très important
c'est à dire que moi je suis assez
favorable au numérique à condition que
parallèlement on n'oublie pas cette
dimension et ce besoin que l'on a de se
retrouver absolument d'associer la
fonction des théâtres la fonction des
théâtres c'est de rassembler des gens
qui ne se ressemblent pas absolument
c'est pas l'un contre l'autre se nomme
avec l'autre est une question justement
elle joséphine colmate verger et horreur
berger on va hier il ya ce projet de loi
qui est en discussion actuellement pour
conforter les principes de la république
justement la culture la culture et la
république et de la culture est le lien
social la culture et le vivre ensemble
c'est comme fondamental pour une société
il me semble moi je pense que la culture
et l'éducation culturelle c'est un
levier indispensable pour une réduction
des inégalités
on le voit c'est quelque chose qui que
l'on ressent je sors un petit peu du
terrain là du monde de riches spectacle
même si ça en fait fortement parti mais
que ce que l'on voit sur le terrain
aujourd'hui et tout à l'heure on
évoquait justement la problématique de
cette paupérisation qui se met en place
n'oublions pas que outre le fait
d'apporter tout ce qui est indispensable
est essentiel au niveau de la nourriture
du logement et de la protection bien sûr
sanitaires il est indispensable
d'accompagner aussi toute cette
population que nous fréquentons et dans
laquelle nous vie
aujourd'hui qui est en grande difficulté
cet apport culturel qui est fondamental
on le reconnaît on le voit nous on
s'aperçoit au sein de certains quartiers
de la nécessité de cette culture et du
changement radical de certains
comportements
permettez moi juste de dire combien
certaines actions mises en place non
seulement par le théâtre de saint
quentin mais par d'autres partenaires
que nous avons sur sur notre département
apporte aujourd'hui un véritable
changement de fond de toutes ces
personnes
l'exemple par exemple de demos qui est
un exemple fort de justement de
musiciens professionnels qui apportent
cette culture auprès d'enfants dits en
difficulté change complètement leur
façon d'être de vivre tant au niveau de
leur famille qu'au niveau de leur
scolarité
donc c'est un tout petit exemple mais
qui concerne les centaines d'enfants sur
le département que nombre d'entre vous
d'entre vous connaissez et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose de
fondamental
je pense que la culture je n'arrive même
pas imaginer qu'on puisse poser la
question qu'est ce que la culture est un
responsable ou fondamental dans notre
société
si avant tout l'humain moi j'entends ça
c'est l'humain il faut impérativement et
comme le disait lionel et beaucoup
d'entre eux
enola ce matin on effectivement dans
quelque chose qui est fondamental au
niveau de l'émotion et au niveau du
rassemblement et de l'humain après tout
se décline de façon différente selon les
périodes selon les zones
selon les nécessités mais en tout cas
l'humain avant tout l'humain avant tout
et je ne veux même plus entendre
est ce que la culture est indispensable
dans notre société ce n'est pas
imaginable qu'encore aujourd'hui à notre
époque ont pu dire ce genre de choses je
ne l'acceptent pas excusez moi d'être
aussi cela dit je crois que peut-être
qu'il est vide et des inexactitudes et
dans les mots employés mais parce que
c'était peut-être pas la volonté de dire
qu'elles n'étaient pas indispensables
justement
je vous en voulez pas non non c'est pas
moi justement aurore bergé et là on est
dans un moment politique où on va
s'interroger sur nos propres valeurs sur
les valeurs que qu'on veut transmettre
sur les valeurs auxquelles on a envie
que toute la société ader est ce que
justement la culture n'est pas plus
importante que jamais pour définir
justement basque ces valeurs ce qui nous
fait vivre ensemble ce qui nous fait ce
à quoi on aime penser ce rapport on
aimerait ressembler mais évidemment je
partage tout les mots de joseph chine
comme sven berger sur sur ce sujet là ça
n'étonnera pas je crois fondamentalement
l'éducation artistique et culturelle je
crois qu'elle est aujourd'hui
insuffisante parce qu'elle elle dépend
encore trop souvent du hasard elle
dépend de la capacité d'avoir ici une
collectivité locale qui va s'en emparer
ici un enseignant ici un artiste qui va
me proposer
il faut que ce soit sur du temps
scolaire obligatoire
il faut que ça rentre dans le quotidien
de tous les enfants de ce pays ça peut
pas uniquement reposer sur la chance du
hasard les belles rencontres
c'est formidable pour ceux qui en
bénéficient mais c'est insuffisant
et là où la culture ou être au contraire
justement un facteur de réduction des
inégalités sociales éducatives
territoriales elle repose que sur la
chance ou du hasard
ça peut même en créer donc c'est là où
il faut absolument que ce soit sur du
temps scolaire obligatoire est que
l'éducation artistique et culturelle qui
est pas uniquement de la pratique qu'est
la rencontre avec les artistes qui est
la rencontre avec les oeuvres qui est
aussi la pratique
demos orchestre à l'école sont en effet
des très beaux exemples de ce lien qui
peut se créer y compris sur les
territoires ça doit être tout et pour
tous les stages crois que c'est
absolument essentiel est certain c'est
que quand on s'interroge sur les valeurs
de la république
on peut pas le faire en france sans
s'interroger sur la place et le rôle de
la culture et je prends le post est
absolument indissociable de notre
identité
tout simplement et ça veut pas dire
qu'il faille pour rebondir
une entité sur une note c'est pas du
tout l'enjeu c'est de faire ensemble
évidemment on défende en vérité la place
de la culture mon jeu d'émancipation en
fait et je crois que c'est aussi cette
sortie de crise qu'on espère tous
j'espère que c'est le aussi l'un des
objectifs qu'on arrivera à attendre
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci
merci merci à tous alors j'espère que
voilà c'est un moment difficile et
naturellement quelques villes la culture
que vit le monde culturel
mais peut-être que derrière tout ça il
ya un peu de un peu de lui à un peu
d'espoir espère que vous la fait donner
l'espérance qu'il faut merci beaucoup à
un berger merci beaucoup
stéphanie tesson merci beaucoup
joséphine scholomance berger et
maintenant la maison et bien sûr lionel
bah c'est à et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de paf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]